come up with a more fun name than loot
box sex container that's just crude and
frankly not appropriate for the show you
come up with something better than party
bag this is versus the GameSpot show
that pits your favorite games consoles
franchises and hot-button issues against
each other this week we're back in good
old Blighty and debating one of the most
divisive topics in gaming loot boxes
arguing the case for is loot box lover
willpower who has spent well over a
hundred quid on overwatch since the game
launched in 2016 because 100 pound Wow
and fighting against loot boxes is
traditionalists Oscar Deus who hates
microtransactions nearly as much as he
loves Queen country and English football
each will argue their case for or
against loot boxes before giving an
example of the game that they believe
backs up their argument you can vote for
who you think has won the argument by
clicking up here now last week's fight
between Wolfenstein and doom saw John
Luke victorious with 64% of the vote for
his argument but doom and now he's
celebrating with a well-earned holiday
right let's get into the debate
hello Oscar hello build what's this
you're wearing
well England lost the World Cup today no
time of recording England are playing
tonight and we're gonna win the World
Cup is coming home okay can I just stop
the football challenge just like that's
Germany you're going home son nice that
was yeah fair enough but absolutely not
because what we're talking about today
talk about micro transactions loot boxes
in particular boxes and I am
wholeheartedly against them irrespective
of whether or not you can pay for them
with real-world money I'm against loot
boxes as a concept the thing I hate most
about them is that it's a complete
show-off device right it's like it
allows people even if they're just
cosmetic it allows people to go oh look
at me I've got this amazing new skin and
I'm richer and better than you and
inherently I think that creates the
divides between people and between
communities and between the gaming
community and I think that's quite an
unsavory thing and then obviously even
if it's worse than that it can affect
the game itself you can be allowed to
purchase randomized weapons or ever then
you're giving it but purely they're
giving actual advantages to people with
more money I don't think so at all I
think if you've put dozens of hours into
a game you'd want to show off that
you've played it a lot I guess it goes
back to like back in the old modern
warfare game to unlock skins and and
weapons and yes nowadays that comes in
the form of loot boxes there's just a
new device to deliver that don't get me
wrong I I do disagree where it gives you
an absolute advantage over other players
yeah maybe don't do that but if it's
purely cosmetic and you can keep the
game fresh and keep you wanting to play
the game to unlock these cool rewards so
you can show off there's nothing wrong
with that I even then though I feel like
it was better in in the olden days of
college it for for example where you
would get high level skins if you got
more headshots and so on because at
least then you felt like you earned it
and whereas now it's just like I've
literally just played X amount of time
I paid X amount of money and I'm not to
loot box and if you get something good
you haven't earned it you just randomly
been given this thing and I think it's
way less satisfying to do that like I
play games with loot boxes in and when I
get something good in a loop box so I
don't go that's an amazing feeling that
feels awesome I've got the sense of
accomplishment you just go oh okay the
algorithm favored me this week but next
week it could be massively against me
and I'll open another ten where at
getting anything good and that's even
before I've got to the the argument of
like the Netherlands and Belgium have
declared that loot boxes are akin to
gambling and also I've got a paper here
from oh yeah
yeah is it's in nature the highly
respected science journal Nature written
by Aaron Drummond and James D Sauer from
Massey University okay cut to the point
in the way they encourage and sustain
user engagement loot box systems share
important structural and psychological
similarities with gambling of those
games containing loot boxes 100% of
those tested allow for if not actively
encouraged underage players to engage
with these systems I'm glad you brought
that up I am glad you brought that up
because you're into football on you I am
yeah yeah
so you familiar with the familiar
familiar with these what are these Oskar
these are football stickers built yeah
and you know exactly what is inside that
football stickers bill yeah which ones
no I don't know exactly you don't know
which ones you're getting no it's fun to
open a pack and be surprised and I know
for a fact
exhibit a that you collect these and you
don't seem to have a massive problem
it's essentially the same as a loot box
it just costs sixty P and it gets you
get stickers instead of skins
I guess my the main difference here is
that my mom always bought me these
didn't come out of my own pocket and so
therefore it's fine let's be real dude a
game for your PlayStation one in 1996
would have cost you $50 yeah taking into
consideration inflation today that would
cost 70 80 up to $100 for a video game
games don't cost that much
reason being is because developers have
implemented things like loot boxes to
offset that cost and if you want to it's
it's up to you you can spend more on
that game if you like it
but I would much rather that extra cash
is obtained by more traditional methods
like map packs you know standard DLC
expansions because then at least I feel
like I'm paying more money but I know
what I'm getting but those are worse
because then you're excluding players
who don't buy map packs not necessarily
because if you're only talking about if
it's a multiplayer shooter for example
like calling to do to your battlefield
but what if you have something like
Rainbow six siege does it really well
where if you want you can pay money and
get those characters early and without
having to grind for them in-game or you
can just grind for them in-game and then
it's free for those people who don't
have so much money unfortunately
Rainbow six siege does also have loot
boxes but they were added in after
launch and actually implemented not too
bad yeah because they don't affect the
game they're just cosmetic it's not bad
but I was still rather they weren't
there if you if you buy loot box and you
get something [ __ ] it's really annoying
and that's always good that sense is
always gonna be there the same as if I
opened one of these and I got I don't
know little messy because he's been
rubbish that's that's you know that's
all in the game isn't it that's part of
the fun see you don't like loot boxes do
you but there's a game I think does them
really well and that's overwatch that
was a lovely here's one we prepared
earlier yes oh yes I bought this
especially today
overwatch does loot boxes it's purely
cosmetic you can get cool skins for your
character you can get sprays voice lines
poses and it feels like a really good
reward for playing the game they even do
event specific ones which I love and
actually I think that works brilliantly
because it gets you playing the game
during events and it's a reason to
revisit that game obviously very clever
but Blizzard to do that but for me I
really don't mind and what also don't
mind is buying a few loot boxes because
with real world money with my own
English Pounds I've probably spent about
a hundred pounds on overwatch loot boxes
I don't remember that
because hundred hang sorry it took me a
second to notice weak 100-pound Wow so I
think it keeps it fresh and also the
behind-the-scenes effective that is
Blizzard and our friend Jeff can carry
on putting all of their efforts into the
game bringing us new content releasing
maps for three new characters for free
keeping servers up and running keeping
the game fresh and they are constantly
thinking about loot boxes and is a good
deal like they went back and changed to
like the drop rate of duplicates they
lowered that so it's actually better
when you get loot boxes so for me I have
no problem buying a game upfront full
price and if I want to treat myself to a
few loot boxes get a nice skin a cool
pose for my character and they will look
amazing as well does it not annoy you
that the system is purely set up not to
satisfy you or not to make you have fun
but to get more money out of you I'm not
that worried because I think overwatch
provides such a great service and I know
that it it couldn't do that if it wasn't
for that ecosystem I wouldn't have this
massive collection of really cool stuff
that I'm proud of own and this massive
hole in your pocket it's not that big to
be honest 100 pounds there right for
serving it over you know you spent a
hundred pound on cheese toasties in a
week I have not it's an absolute lie
anybody pret I know you did I've got an
example here built of again that I think
is done new books is particularly badly
all right let's see despite being a good
game and that is Star Wars Battlefront 2
which at launch let's face it was an
absolute mess when it comes to its loot
boxes and its microtransactions probably
yeah one of the most controversial
launchers of a game yeah yeah
essentially the way it works at launch
you could pay real world money or
in-game currency to buy crate inside
crates for star cars which were
essentially how you progress through the
game with your with your character this
obviously caused a lot of controversy
and dice were forced to reduce some of
the costs of various things that you can
buy in the game as well as eventually
taking my turn micros and actions out
altogether
and it stayed that way for months and
they always said they were gonna bring
them back and now they finally have as
of a couple of months ago you can no
longer buy anything that's tied to
progression you can only earn star cards
through playing the game but there are
still loot boxes only with purely
cosmetic items in them which is a bit
not ideal but it is a lot better than
what it was before but I think this
shows how the negative reception that
battlefront II received was almost
entirely because of this progression
system and it's like people really hate
this stuff and understandably so because
I think it's so egregious and so it
takes advantage of people and I think
it's a prime example of how badly
microtransactions and loot boxes can
affect the gaming community and III
can't argue that when bow front 2 came
out it was a shining example of how
elite boxes should work as much as I do
like supporting companies who make games
with you know extra income for stuff
that I can get on top of the game yeah I
don't think it should impact progression
in such a way on the flip side I played
back front 2 a lot and I never really
felt like I was at disadvantage because
I hadn't spent money on that game mmm
like I think the advantages you got was
so small at least for me not playing
that like a top level I never really
noticed it I never felt all that person
killed me because they had so-and-so
star card which you can get through just
normally play in the game so I think it
was blown out of proportion a tiny bit
but saying that I do agree that they
went down the dark side I can't defend
it I'm glad it's gone back to cosmetics
I think that's how loot boxes should be
done like we don't want like a class
system in games where the richer are
beating the poorer that is some weird
dystopian future and I'm glad this
happened because it obviously made such
a shift in the way publishers and
developers think about games that it's
probably not going to happen again at
least for the foreseeable future because
of what we've now seen it so what you're
saying is
you're glad this happened because it
means that games don't have loot boxes
anymore and that's a good thing
no I'm glad there how are you on my side
and therefore I win no I'm glad they do
have loot boxes I think loot boxes
should stay but do it properly
and I don't think you can say that's a
bad thing really can you well I'm sure I
can I can sit here and argue toss for
six hours yeah you do run your mouth off
a lot same sign in the play and I want
to get home so far we've wrapped the
start see down the pub boys inform or
football stickers so who do you think
won the debate let us know by voting in
our poll in the top right corner of this
video or if you're on GameSpot calm by
putting your thoughts in the comment
section below
it'll be your voice at the side who wins
so make yourselves heard before
Oscar heads down to the pub to watch
football coming home we've got time for
this week's quickfire round a series of
dumb fun questions written by the rest
of the UK team let's see how the guys
get on if you have to randomize either
what your meals are or what you wear
which would it be well you've already
done the latter haven't you wait this
takes weeks of planning or happy you
know so I'll go for meals actually
because I spend so much time on my day
thinking what am I gonna eat yeah well
actually be quite fun yeah it would stop
me from eating bad foods as well what I
know here on toast well let's get where
the fruits about what is the name of
unique currency used to buy loot boxes
in your life in my life yeah England
coins dollar bills horse armor yay or I
just added by any that wasn't written I
just like made up the sound effect
alright this is that what you're working
with
oh yes horse imma make it like cool
cyberpunk laser beams metal armor white
with guns on nay come up with a more fun
name than looped box sex container
that's just crude and frankly not
appropriate for the show you come up
with something better than party bag if
you were a loop box how much would a key
to open you be me I'll be 99 P because
I'm cheap and easy just like ice cream
[Applause]
[Laughter]
remember to get your voice heard in our
poll or in the comments section below
and tell us who you think argued the
case better and if you enjoyed this
episode of vs. make sure to hit that
subscribe button as we'll have new
episodes of the show every Wednesday
thanks for watching see ya
[Music]
you